From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're on the road again. There we go.
This is David Klein for the Smithsonian and the National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Today is Friday March the 1st and I'm in Berlin, Gain, California.
And Mr. Steve McNichols, good morning.
Good morning.
Thank you very much for talking with us today.
The pleasure is mom.
Okay. What I'd like to do, Steve, is first just ask you to tell us a little bit about where you were raised and the family that you were raised in.
Yeah, I'd like to dwell for just a moment on my origins if I may because it's important.
My maternal grandparents, yet so I can own a Frank, emigrated from Eastern Europe, Riga (Latvia) and Marijampolė to Palestine in 1890.
And we're part of an emigration movement sponsored by the Rothschild.
In fact, I'm thinking it works for the Rothschild.
And they moved to Palestine where they found in, or one of 11 families who founded the city of Tel Aviv,
which instantaneously gives me more status in Israel than I ever have anywhere else, you know.
And their names are engraved on Founders Monument.
I have a picture of my uncle standing in front of Founders Monument.
And my grandfather built the first residential dwelling home in Tel Aviv.
It's a part of me, which is on a tour, a lot of the tours that go through Tel Aviv.
And my mother was born there.
And then when my mother was five years old, my grandmother was having health problems.
So they separated and she moved to Geneva with my grandparents and my mother relocated to Geneva.
Where she became a classically trained violinist and was Joseph Szigeti's prodigy people and toured with them before coming to the United States.
Which was probably a mistake. I think the whole family should have stayed in Geneva.
That's where their hands were at.
But they moved to what the United States, along with André Kostelanetz and some other people.
And that background is very important to me, even though I'm not observant, not an observant too.
But it's important to me as a person, you know, and something I feel strongly about.
So I was born in New York in 1939.
My mother was here at this classically trained violinist.
Her violin was stolen as soon as she hooked up with my father, no connection.
And she stopped playing violin for 14 years.
My father was brought up in a very tough neighborhood in St. Louis.
He was a thunk who was murdered when my father was three.
And my father was a very tough guy.
Very smart, actually. Intellectually curious, well-rained, read.
But I think he got a GED.
And I didn't appreciate him enough as a child.
Because I was supposed to be a genius.
And I discovered what the word percussius really means.
It means that your way ahead of everybody else up to about age 13,
and then your parents start passing you.
And instead of being, you know, so much more brilliant than they are,
you're lucky to stay in the top thurn.
I mean, but we lived in a very tough neighborhood in New York.
133rd Street, you know.
I was the only white kid in my neighborhood.
And but I went to Dalton School when in most prestigious private schools in the country
on a full scholarship.
So during the day I was going to school with children of some of the wealthiest people in the country.
(W. Averell) Harriman, nephew, Marshall Field III's niece, and others, many others.
And then I would return to the ghetto at night.
And it was an economist who gets what it exists since for me.
Because I was very sensitive and very impressionable,
very conscious of the fact that I came from a very poor background
and lived in a very poor neighborhood.
What was the racial ethnic composition of that neighborhood?
I was the only white kid in the neighborhood.
Puerto Rican.
And I was lucky because it still was not as bad as he's told me.
It was bad.
I finally went to work one day in small bodily line in the street.
And because I lived there, I grew up there.
I got along with the other kids pretty much.
We had fights.
When other than that I was accepted.
I was Steve who was kind of the strange kid who lived in the neighborhood.
So being that you had this, you know, we were like in this in the neighborhood.
In the neighborhood and they're going to Dalton School,
were you thinking about race and difference in class at all the young age you remember?
It was in the air.
I couldn't help but think about it because I was surrounded by it.
But my goal was to get the hell out of them.
And my mother was driving me to succeed.
So I wouldn't have the same kind of life that she had.
What did your father do for work?
Whatever he could.
I mean, he had very as sort of an uninteresting job.
He worked in a lab, animal facility.
But through his credit, just to show you what kind of a man he was,
he started taking electronics courses.
And taught himself radio and television electronics
and then became a trainee for Picker X-Ray Corporation.
And most of his peers had engineering degrees.
And he was the top trainee in his training class when they were best repairmen.
So he was remarkable really in his own way.
I couldn't have done that.
So my phone separated.
My mother was very anxious to leave my father, which was really a mistake.
And we separated.
And remarkably, she supported herself by teaching French to employees of time life
and started making a very good living.
The first time we had money in my life.
And then, unfortunately, she developed psychiatric symptoms
and had a big breakdown in the middle of the time life lobby
at noon one day.
And she was institutionalized.
The whole thing fell apart.
And I went back to living with my father.
I was 16.
And my father really stepped into the bridge,
because I'm not sure it was necessary that he'd do.
But he really came through like Gamebusters,
even though we never really got along.
But he really saved my neck,
psychiatric, like speaking.
And I went into a permanent depression.
Every day of my life since about age 15,
I suffered from suicidal ideation for 15 years.
Until we discovered when I was 65 years old,
that I actually have a bipolar condition.
Once we started training that, the depression lifted.
And I started, I became much more fortunate, as a person.
What did you do?
What was the treatment for bipolar?
Lithium.
But I didn't get any treatment,
because I wasn't diagnosed as bipolar.
So my whole life was spent seeing chiroats
who were treating me for depression,
when they should have been treating me for bipolar condition.
Not one of them guessed there was a bipolar condition.
It was only by accident when this came in age 65.
When my cardiologist, I returned from accident,
where I've been living.
And sent me for a panel of tests.
One of the tests, you know,
the lab technician wrote down that my lithium serum level
was virtually non-existent.
When it turns out, which is not really in thinking of a beam
by a Portland, but triggered an investigation, you know, a review.
But so starting in your teens, you're...
Well, the whole episode with my mother being in situation,
was very living with my mother for two years watching.
The tearing of it, it's like the accurately,
was extremely depressing.
You know?
I was extremely isolated.
I mean, I had friends,
but I was in a world by myself.
My mother and I were both seen as psychiatrist,
who was, in my opinion, totally irresponsible and unprofessional.
And when he concluded that we both had psychiatric problems,
he just ran in the opposite direction,
instead of helping us deal with it.
I'll never forget them.
You know?
I'd like to run into them now, if I had any strength.
It was very sad.
On the other hand,
to musical ashamed, it was a tremendous learning experience.
So, that was around age 16,
so you're the next couple of years?
It was when I turned my 16th part to...
March of 15th.
I was going to fly, I think.
So, take me for the next couple of years?
Well, I was going to start this in high school.
And my father and I
gradually kind of separated from each other.
We still lived together, supported me,
but he started spending more and more time with his girlfriend,
and I didn't care for him.
And I was on my own more and more.
And then I remember I was lying in bed,
and I was talking with my father.
We had a real one apartment.
And so, what are you going to do, Steve?
He said, you're 18 years old.
What are you going to do after you graduate from Stuyvesant?
And I don't know where it came from,
but I was trying to become a champion tennis player.
I got the idea that I would leave home,
go to Los Angeles, play tennis and work for you
in the Golden UCLA.
And I laid it out for me, said, that's it.
That's perfect.
And that's what I did.
And I got into a car with somebody else
who was driving to Denver, drove to Denver.
Soon LA arrived and LAX, and I didn't know anybody.
Had some money, then my father gave me,
ran in a room at the YMCA, and started to work,
and support myself,
and started my long soldier in that UCLA.
What I spent about twice is what's time,
and I really needed it.
And what point did you go back to your mother again?
Did they discover what was going on with your mother?
Well, after seven or eight years,
her tumor became so bad that she couldn't walk
without staggered.
And that's when some nurses,
someone said, say, I think she's got a physical problem.
And that's when they discovered it.
And that's when they operated to remove her tumor.
You know, they get down to some tasks from what happened.
But it was too late.
Well, they blew the operand.
Another doctor I'd like to get my hands off.
Yeah, they took the tumor out,
but didn't replace it with anything.
And half an hour after the operation,
the walls of a brain collapse since he died.
So I had a phone call asking for authority
since I was the young woman of Ken
to do the operation.
And then I get another phone call saying she died.
And that was her life.
That was the last 10 years of her life.
And she says, beautiful, culture,
educated, woman, never had a chance.
With a medical install.
Sure.
And so you were in Los Angeles at that?
I was in LA.
Working and supporting myself and going to UCLA.
And every spare moment I had was devoted to the Civil Rights Movement.
So what were you, first of all, what were you studying at UCLA?
Well, I didn't know what I wanted.
I was lost.
The whole UCLA scene was alien to me.
I arrived on campus and there were all these middle class kids
running around.
I couldn't really identify what's anymore.
But interestingly enough, I plunged into student politics,
which is how I got involved in the Civil Rights Movement.
And so I'm climbing the political ladder in UCLA.
It came very active politically.
Made some pretty heavy white contact.
Howard Berman and Henry Waxman were part of their machine.
And they came active in the National Student Association.
Went to National Student Association conferences.
And just started climbing the political ladder.
Any way I could.
What year about?
Well, I actually interviewed UCLA in 58.
So what was the National Student Association concerned with?
What were the major issues, I guess, at that point?
Well, the major issues were international.
There was this cold war going on between International Union of Students,
which I believe was a communist front.
I know what's going on in the front.
And I'll mention the International Student Conference.
If I don't have them confused, I don't think I knew.
And our people were being trained by the CIA
and going off to conferences all over the world
in this cold war to influence other student union.
And there was some pretty hairy episode.
You know, we had people, and we had half a dozen offices around the world.
There was the International Student Conference,
had a secretary in, in, in Europe.
And the CIA was spending money and assigning,
hemingwights to run this network.
It was a CIA network.
And the head of the network was a guy named Bob Kiley,
who'd been president of National Student Association,
which sent the whole network up.
And...
He became...
why am I going to work for the CIA?
And ultimately, he became Richard Helms Special Assistant.
And there's some interesting stories about that.
But back at UCLA, what were the primary things that you were involved in?
Well, we got caught up on the whole thing.
So we thought we were important,
because we were a part of this.
We didn't realize it was a CIA front.
You know, we thought we were just students doing it.
With certain foundations.
And the youth and student foundations involved things.
Can you imagine?
You're running this network.
And you have something called the Youth and Student Foundation,
and it's absurd.
You know, you might as well have said,
hey, we're over here.
You know?
So what first drew you to what was going on with the Civil Rights and the United States?
I don't know, but from the moment I heard him on the Senate,
I was a tranquil.
I wanted to go on a Senate.
I wanted him to be involved.
Freedom Rider".
And it was, you know, to me, it was a chosen thing.
I would be lucky if I could be a Freedom Rider".
And that's how I felt about it.
How are you getting news about these things?
Well, that's what's so interesting,
because the L.A. Times,
another news outlet that's weren't really covering the movement.
So we had a brummolum through kind of a pipeline from the east to the west.
So we heard about the Senate,
long before anybody else in the L.A. knew about it.
And I didn't get it.
I was from New York.
Why were people sitting in?
And Kresge's on what happened?
He looks.
That didn't make sense to me.
We need less where we wanted.
You know?
And then after a while,
it thought them in what was really going on here.
Then it couldn't go to Kresge's or whatever.
In the south, the Midwest,
in the east,
blacks couldn't be served.
I was stunned. I was shocked.
And that's when we started to throw ourselves into the movement.
And we started having,
I didn't really participate in any of the time in the Shantan.
It was very active in a student political party.
I was at a platform,
the student political party in UCLA.
And we all,
my students in the U.S.
started demonstrating outside of Kresge's and other places.
To let people in.
And lunch counter, you know.
Yeah, demonstrations.
Mostly white students are,
were there white students?
Like, the students were very appetizing.
All they cared about,
I had to say that it was true at that time.
All they cared about was parties.
Their social life.
They would get together in the same part of the cafeteria every day.
Socialized with each other.
Eight lunch.
And then split.
That's all they cared about.
And we had a hard time getting involved.
We kept trying to get them involved.
And it took several years before they even got involved.
And then they finally didn't get involved.
Well, I went to had,
to real implications,
there was a shooting in UCLA.
You know,
which happened after I left.
I was shocked.
You know, because I didn't think he's sailing with him.
I know what to.
Fine.
So can you tell me just a little bit about how,
the idea of having freedom rights leave from less Angeles,
and how you all plan that activity.
Yeah, it's a funny story.
There are two black attorneys in Houston.
George Washington,
Junior,
and Hayma K.
Hayma, H-A-M-A-H, K.
And these guys were real hustlers.
Although they were all from very good attorney,
very good civil rights attorney.
And they were so driven
that they were challenging the black establishment,
which wanted nothing to do with, okay?
They even formed their own black club.
I forget the name of him,
my old history partner.
And they got the idea of
arranging for a freedom rights to come to Houston.
And the third member of this trail
was a guy named Theodore "Hugo" Brooks.
Theodore "Hugo" Brooks.
He was a great guy.
He was a crook.
He was a fence.
He owned five,
he owned five gloves
and then fifth wore.
And it was very funny because on the one hand,
he was extremely bourgeois,
but very upset when he discovered
we're in the same jail with an infamous young woman
who had murdered the man who kept her.
I mean, he was just blown away by that.
And his daughter also was a freedom writer,
when that's on the Freedom Rider".
So they got Mr. Theodore "Hugo" Brooks
to put up the necessary cash.
And they called James Farmer
and said, hey, all the freedom lines
pretty much had gone.
Although it was still two or three women in Noam Island,
and they said, let's send them freedom lines to Houston.
And we will take care of the cost
to a couple thousand dollars
and represent them.
Yeah, James Farmer was head of corps
who had found that corps
was one of the original freedom lines.
And Farmer was in New York,
and Farmer was great.
So for some reason they decided to send this freedom
from the layout.
I don't know why, maybe it stopped sending freedom lines
from New York.
And Los Angeles Corps,
which was headed up by a great guy,
what was his name I can see in his face
and come back to me.
So I didn't want to see them freedom lines.
And that's when I discovered
I was a student at UCLA at the time
and dropped down in New Zealand.
I thought, oh my God, that's great.
I've got a chance to go on a Freedom Rider".
I didn't mean Freedom Rider".
And that's when I'm volunteering
for the Houston Freedom Rider".
And that's when they started putting it together.
I was asked you that question again.
So the director of LA Corps was...
Arnold Walters.
And he was being challenged
by a couple of very ambitious black people, guys.
And we were doing a great job
with sort of holding him off.
They kept trying to make him look bad.
Henry Hards,
and the other one who later became a state senator,
pardon me.
I can see his face.
I can't remember his name.
Bill, so many are other.
And they kept trying to undermine him with the group.
No.
Anything they can do to a marathon,
make him look bad,
humiliate him,
and he hung in there anyway.
Because he was extremely important for him to stay there.
And not be driven out of the group.
And to this day, I'm trying to remember the name
of the guy who became a state senator
who was a state senator.
When they heard about the Freedom Rider" of the Houston,
Henry Hards and the other guy,
a meanling jump time that's saying,
one go, one go on the Houston.
One go on the Freedom Rider" of the Houston.
Of course they never showed up.
That's a historical.
I remember standing on the train
and looking around,
they were nowhere to be seen.
It was pretty funny.
Was there a Walter Green ball didn't get you up together?
Was there a Walter Green ball didn't get you together?
Oh yeah, they sponsored the Freedom Rider".
They got the money, they wanted tickets,
and for the ticket,
and they trained us.
Can you tell me about what that training was?
It's a good question,
because they really didn't help us very much.
It was basically a lot of stuff we spent two days
in somebody's home practicing situations,
but we're so funny about it,
all focused on being attacked by a white mob
at a union station.
Nothing about what to do after you were arrested.
So it was virtually no help.
They can't be using me to try to
be the white racist attacking them,
but I couldn't pull it off.
I mean, I couldn't even get upset.
You know, I didn't have anything against my friend.
Just funnier than hell.
So what was also funny is
that Ellen Kleinman,
when I showed up the first day at
Ellen Core, was told to show up.
I was the second person I think
to volunteer for that funeral.
And Ellen Kleinman had just gone down the union station,
bought some tickets and returned.
And I remember telling them,
two railroad companies
that went to Houston.
And she didn't know which one to get.
So she just got one of them and turned out to be the wrong one.
Because the one she got was for Southern Pacific.
And we didn't know it until we actually arrived in Houston.
But they had gotten rid of their lunch counter
and replaced it with vending machine.
So there was no way we could in and drink them,
but that's where we were headed.
So we went on leaving on our ninth
to go on the freedom ride to Houston, Texas.
Who was in the group of how many were you in?
There were 11 of us.
And Bob Coppin was from Berkeley.
And I didn't know this, but apparently he was a prominent
member of the Communist Party.
And Henry Hodgson elected him
to be in charge of our freedom ride.
And was attacked for doing that,
while other core members.
So how many how many men and women black and white?
I think it was five and six.
I'm trying to remember.
So we only had the couple of black.
We had 12 for our
with a member of the West Coast student movement, really.
That's how we all really got involved.
We had all been involved in the West Coast student movement.
And there were several of them.
And we went on the leaning on the end
and the end of the moon and arrived in the morning and day and later.
And Houston.
And the train trip itself was uneventful or eventful?
Uneventful, except for the fact that an FBI agent joined our group in El Paso.
And he really looked like an FBI.
He was this big, husky, older guy.
Very well dressed.
And the black, the black porters told us
that he was going to join our farm.
I'm sorry.
Our group, you know, in El Paso.
And I'm sitting there and we pull into El Paso.
And I suddenly looked up and here's this guy coming right into our...
We had the whole car,
practically, to ourselves.
You know, the porters would set us up so we could have meanings and so on and so forth.
So you got some support from the train porters?
Oh, tremendous.
On the way down there and the way back was different.
Because we were very bitter on the way back.
And suddenly I looked up and here's this guy.
I mean, he was obviously an FBI agent.
I remember dropping something because I was so shocked.
And he was just walked up nearby and sat down and went into the neighborhood.
And somebody asked him if he worked for the railroad he said he did.
Well, of course, he was an FBI agent.
And then we showed up in Houston.
And we discovered when we showed up in Houston,
there was no lunch counter.
Nothing to innovate.
And George Washington and Hayman King arranged to pick us up and take us to their office.
And the local freedom runners with progressive student association.
And that's where we went.
And we went in there while they changed our tickets to the other, you know, other terminal.
So we would have tickets to the right terminal.
And were you, did you have tickets on from Houston or was it just to Houston?
I'm sorry.
Did you have, we supposed to go on from Houston?
No, this is what's so interesting.
We were told that, if I may say so, God blessed me with a rather extraordinary, long-term memory.
I can't remember where I put my car keys, but I remember things, dating by 50 years.
No problem.
I know what happened.
Now what happened is we were told that we weren't going to use them.
And if we were not arrested in Houston, because we were there to integrate, you know, the coffee shop.
And we were there in a challenge.
The law in Texas.
We would then go on to Jackson, Mississippi.
But our tickets didn't connect to Jackson.
And they weren't supposed to.
We were to go into Houston, okay?
Now there are people who believe that we were supposed to go on to Jackson.
And Houston was just kind of a, you know, almost an afterthought.
That's not right.
I mean, after all, Hema and George wanted us all to think and raise money.
And we were representing us.
And you had the progressive student association.
Not just half a dozen people, but they had supporters in Houston.
So the whole thing, Houston was the target for us.
Unless, if we had walked up to the coffee shop, and we had been in a minute, and we had these things we were getting in the coffee shop,
then we would have gone on to Jackson.
Otherwise, you know, I do want to get arrested in Houston.
Challenge, I think there were some local statutes, you know, segregation statutes, gym front statutes.
And when we were challenging all of that.
Were you getting news from Jackson?
Do you know what was going on there with the other?
Yeah.
We wouldn't get occasionally.
Love would call New York Corps.
And we wouldn't be told about something.
And that was it.
So, take us, we'll start again from where.
You
We're rolling.
Okay.
Thank you.
And let's start with, I guess you took us to the office.
Yeah, we were taking.
And then we were taking to a black restaurant.
We set up an apartment lot.
And what it was was a, a, what's the term I'm thinking of?
You know, when you go and you get black food.
So food.
So food restaurant.
First time I ever had so food.
I was shocked at having been attested.
You know, I looked at it.
I said, hmm, what's this?
You know, anyone's, you know, whatever it was.
And it was delicious.
Just delicious.
And when you think about a sludge.
I mean, while Bob.
And I think one of the attorneys were changing our tickets.
And they came back.
They picked us up.
And then afternoon we went to the union station.
And we went in.
And the union.
The union city.
The union.
The union center.
A lunch counter.
One's run by a guy whose name I'm just for, just let my mind.
Terrible racist.
And we formed a line in front of the place.
While he held the door shut so we couldn't come in.
So he found and walked away from the door so we can come in.
And he can have us arrested.
And we were, you had joined up with the progressive student association.
How many?
I'm sorry.
You had joined forces at this point with members of the progressive student association.
Yeah, there were 18 of us all together.
Can you describe the group of 18?
I don't know what to tell you.
We're all well dressed.
It was in the day when everybody who participated in demonstrations.
When we're coats and ties.
You know, before the moronical dress wear.
And very well mannered.
And we just stood in line.
And meanwhile Bob and others kept calling out to the guy who.
Owned the lunch counter.
What was his name?
Asking him to let us in.
Anybody who walked away let us in.
And took us a moment of real life we can walk in.
And we walked in and sat down.
At the lunch counter and at some booth.
And it was very interesting because
we saw everybody with me in Gantathus.
But some people weren't there.
The Winchester's were all for us.
And there's our whispering to us.
And I remember we sat a couple of sarcastic things.
But you don't want us here and they said, oh no, oh no.
We want you here.
White Winchester.
And you know, that really sounds a lot.
That the working Winchester's white one or none say.
We're all for it.
They couldn't say so because they would lose their jobs.
And we took meanwhile a crown assemble.
And the police were sent for.
And right outside.
In the parking lot really, but right in front of the door.
And we were told that they wanted us to leave, of course.
A couple of guys showed up who threatened us as part of the crowd.
But they never followed up on it.
We one day we walked back for the clothes.
And I'll take care of them.
Never had the guts to walk in and actually confront us.
Of course, you know.
We were paying to the, you know, the none.
What's the word I'm joking for?
Nonviolent.
Standards.
We weren't necessarily nonviolent.
We weren't being nonviolent.
Can you tell me a little bit more about that so you had studied it.
But if I have to sort of conflict, did you see that there might be other ways?
But this was one way too.
And I'm trying to say.
Yeah.
I mean, I really want to be nonviolent.
And core was nonviolent.
And core was really nonviolent.
I mean, they weren't faking it.
It was important enough.
But I wasn't nonviolent.
I mean, I came out of my top name of a new New York.
As far as I'm concerned, we can be nonviolent.
I mean, you know.
We can be the shit out of them if we could, you know.
We can care.
But I was so, by that time, I was so, I was almost religious.
I was so committed to core in the freedom of life.
In fact, when we first got on the, on the, on the train and left LA.
We were told to stay away from the bar car, not sing freedom song.
And within about 15 minutes, we were in the bar car singing freedom song.
And I was offended by that.
I thought that was wrong, you know.
But then I, I had a train, a soft train.
And I sort of complained in a very pure way.
And I was like, I'm not confident about it.
And he said, I'm having a scotch.
You know.
So.
And two of the guys who went with us had brought some marijuana on board with them.
And two or three of them hung out in the bedroom smoking marijuana.
You know, it was obvious.
We were a lot of giggling and hung out in the bedroom.
So when we arrived in, we were actually sitting.
I started getting scared.
And I remember turning to the guy next to me, the local student,
saying, you know, I am really beginning to get scared.
I don't know if I can knew this.
And he forced me to call me down and reinforce me.
And then when we arrested, one of the local students was the last to be arrested.
He stood up and announced everybody said, make my come to go.
And even guys who had been threatening white guys started laughing.
And telling them it's hysterical, you know.
And we were arrested.
And we were not treated badly.
And we were taken in these small, you know, cars, cars to jail.
And we were treated well.
We drove very carefully, so we didn't have a lot of bounces.
Did the police talk to you during that?
Huh?
Did the police officers talk to you while they were?
No.
They didn't care.
You know, the layners and couple of them talked to us, but not much.
And when we were taking to the city jail,
and then transferred to the county jail,
when we started having problems.
So that's how we got arrested.
So then you were booked in and charged?
Well, we were booked in Montesonia and the county's yard.
But it was really the county jail.
We were thrown into these holding cells.
And we were processed through the booking.
And it was very funny because we would be processed as, you know.
Well, the first thing that happened is they would pull us out.
And the white males, we were in the middle cell, a holding cell.
And they started pulling people from the other cells first.
And gradually as time passed, the number of people in the holding cells
really started going down because the others were being placed in the black tanks.
You know, like the two black tanks.
And then finally, also,
we were finally pulled into that to be booked at about two o'clock in the morning.
So just to clarify, they were white men were put in one place in black men
and another in white women and black women.
That's right.
Different tanks.
Yeah.
Well, they just had one white male tank and one white female tank.
And what the black one put in separate black tanks.
And we were taken up to be photographed and booked and Steve,
I can see his face.
And I just can't remember his name at the moment.
But he refused to cooperate.
Which was a mistake.
And Steve, you know,
we were told to say yes or no sir, but the guy who was processing us
and Steve started talking back to us, which was a mistake.
So I'm done there.
And I remember saying, oh no, for God's sake don't do that.
But in a very sarcastic voice started talking back to the guy who was processing us.
And I don't know if they were going to beat us up before that.
I guess since they were.
But that's certainly finalized.
And we were then taken upstairs at about two o'clock in the morning
and put in the white male misdemeanor tank.
And I remember the deputy sheriff telling us to tell
the prisoners what we were arrested for.
And it's a point of that was to let the prisoners know that we were the freedom ones.
Because I'm like an idiot, I want them to tell them I'm an arrested friend lawful assembly.
And the president said, you know one of those fucking ningo lovers.
And went, oh, oh.
And we quickly found ourselves surrounded.
About a half dozen tough looking guys surrounded us,
and started putting us down verbally,
and then walked us into the back and told us to lay down.
And take off our shoes and learn that.
And I didn't feel comfortable doing that.
But I didn't really have a choice.
And we took our shoes off and lay down.
And once we lay down, they all started shouting at us.
And the whole tank was covered with fire.
You know, how many people were in the tank?
107.
And they were on, when I first walked in, all of a sudden,
these just outlined.
And they were on the line on tables, on benches, on the floor.
You know, so, it's sort of a strange outline.
I didn't know what the hell I was looking at.
Yeah.
You were traveling in the smoke?
Well, I had a hard time adjusting.
I couldn't forget what it is then.
You know, what the hell is that?
And after a while, I mean, and then Donna means those were people
who were trying to sleep.
And then when we were taken in the Mac,
and told them to lay down, we lay down.
And that's when they started beating us up.
And of the people who surrounded us, half of those people,
there was one in particular, who was a real sadness.
And he started pounding Steve's ribs,
which was throwing a painful.
And Steve started screaming,
and then the other started kicking Steve,
rolling and lying in a row.
And then he jumped up,
and I was looking around, and suddenly he came flying to the air
at me, and landed on me,
and the guy right next to me,
chose Stevenson,
knelt down and started pounding me.
And I started a panic,
and I started to raise up.
I was trying to run,
and the more I ran up, the harder he hit me.
And I realized I couldn't do that.
I had to lie down and lay still,
which was consistent with my youth in the ghetto.
And if you were beating me enough,
that's how you didn't have the muscle.
That's how you handled it.
And when I lay still,
they only went a few more minutes,
and then they stopped beating me up,
and you know, started beating up the others.
Bob Kaufman and Steve Sanfield,
but Steve Sanfield had already been beaten up,
and was heavily pounding.
He got the telegrams pounding.
And Joe Stevenson,
the youngest one of our group,
flipped over on his tummy and lay still,
and was completely overlooked,
wasn't beating at all.
So three of us were worked over,
and Joe wasn't.
So finally,
they stopped working on sofa,
and the top con,
were walking around in a circle,
and screaming at us,
and trying to beat us up.
And we weren't just frozen in fear, you know?
And frozen here,
for the rest of the night,
while they walked back and forth,
threatening to beat us up.
So what kind of injuries did you guys have at that point?
Well, I and her knee didn't end this,
but I didn't know it.
You know?
I had these feelings,
but I didn't realize it was a hurling in and out.
Bob was kicked in the face,
manged up against the bars,
and opened up a two-inch wound behind his left ear.
Steve was kicked in the left eye,
which was very painful,
and then he was also beaten up elsewhere,
and that was what we experienced.
And so,
the dawn slowly came,
and when we waited for dawn to come,
we were slowly came,
and then coffee arrived for the present,
and we were in effect,
and we were slowly integrated into the group,
by the present.
In other words,
they had been told to beat us up.
The guards had told them to beat us up.
They might have wanted to beat us up anyway,
I'm not sure.
But it was consistent,
not all of them felt that way.
Some of them felt that way.
And half the prisoners were in large wells,
and the other half were in the dining area,
where you had about 50 prisoners,
lying there.
And we lay here for a couple hours,
and I was so scared I didn't move for a couple of hours.
And then the dawn came,
and they slowly started letting
the prisoners ran the tank,
slowly started letting other prisoners in us
actually stand up,
and kind of express ourselves a little bit.
You know?
We were allowed to have some coffee,
and then the breakfast showed up,
and as dawn came,
everybody stood up,
the whole time stood up,
and the tank basically came to life,
and we're in the middle of a hundred and seven prisoners.
You know, I didn't know what the story was.
I don't know if they hated us or what.
But as it turned out,
not all of the white prisoners were against us.
Some of them said they were
actually supporting us,
although when it came down to it,
that wasn't the case.
They didn't support us.
It's too much to home for.
And then dawn came,
starting the breakfast,
which I think was a jester.
An oatmeal-type cereal,
and something in the whole of the breakfast.
And we had a thing of black coffee,
and suddenly they started treating us well.
And the guy who actually ran the tank
started treating us decently.
You know?
Who actually interacted with some of the other prisoners?
Yeah, and we weren't very nervous about it,
naturally since we'd all been mean up.
None of the other prisoners were at that moment.
A little later,
they started, you know,
approaching us individually.
And several of them said they were green ones.
They were with us,
although it was a practical matter,
when the tank pulled around two days later,
they went there, you know,
they didn't support us.
So,
but people were watching,
you know what happened for us?
We ain't what happened.
And I remember,
one of the prisoners was attempting to be
an author of me, his fork,
which he had watched off.
I was reluctant to tank it,
because I thought maybe he was coming onto me.
I had no idea.
But he was trying to show some sympathy for us,
as the several others.
So, the one presence there
was trying to demonstrate some sympathy.
That's important in what we were doing.
So, what was the philosophy of core
or given in particular in terms of going,
being all or staying in prison if you ever.
We weren't supposed to stay in there until we were trying,
which we didn't do,
because we were bailed out.
We had an email though.
Because our lives were really threatened,
you know, later, two days later.
Were you on agreement about that
or did you discuss it while you were in there?
No, we agreed to do whatever we were going to discuss it.
And...
So, that was pretty much it.
We had a surviving tank.
Two days.
About 48 hours.
And then what happened at the end of that?
Okay.
Do you want any of this information about two days?
Yes, sure.
Well, it was very interesting.
First of all, it was a misdemeanor tank.
All right?
You had all kinds of prisoners here.
You were in people who had never been arrested before.
You were in people who had career criminals.
The tank was controlled by a small clique.
And the head con was known as the commander.
His name was Garland.
And he was in cell number one.
He had like seven-rate cells.
And the first couple of cells were only occupied 50%.
The members of cell number one
would sleep in the mom cells
and put their own personal stuff on the top cells.
And the whole damn tank was overcrowded.
It didn't matter.
The lieutenant commander,
Omer Street,
roamed the tank,
which was...
There were two tanks.
The whole...
The whole area was called the tank.
And then the dining area,
when we slept, was also known as the tank.
So the head of the tank, Omer Street,
was commander of both the whole thing
and was in charge of the dining area.
Well, Garland,
when we walked up and down,
you know, the hallway between the two areas
and spent a lot of time
trying to handle his own, you know.
Um...
He was just clenched the wood sand.
He was pretty burned out.
But that's how we survived.
It was by running the tank.
And he was...
Really...
The Z arm of the guard.
Whenever he wanted, he did.
Whenever he wanted to do,
he wouldn't get there permission to do first.
For the most part,
depending on how important it was.
So, we weren't just kind of surviving.
And we slowly got to meet and to know many of the prisoners.
Then the prisoners would come up to us
and insist that we were nigger lovers
and we were, you know, sort of lucky to be alive.
And some of them's prisoners were very dangerous.
There was a guy
who was in charge of...
What was he in charge of?
I'm sorry.
Well, there was one guy
who came on the scene later.
Who was the most dangerous guy in the deal?
And his...
He had been in the...
He had been arrested from murder.
I was in a felony tank.
Three guys,
under the presence of the sign-in or jump him.
And the body slipped him away from blame.
And he used that blame to cut off slurps.
And all three were hospital.
He got him one of them touched.
He went real.
I don't know how to tell you how dangerous it was.
I mean, this guy...
No one even interacted with him without being scared enough.
He went assigned the oldest, shankiest guard
to tank it.
He was in solitary confinement
six days a week.
And the oldest guard
was walking back to solitary confinement.
And would be shaking like a leaf.
But they would assign him
because he was no threat to the president.
They didn't want the president to kill him.
You know?
I had to wonder where they put him in the misdemeanor tank once a week.
Because they felt that if they didn't do that, he'd go crazy.
And once they'd damn him,
a little bit of freedom.
You know, some latitude.
They wanted him to associate with other presidents.
And would spend the day sociolodizing
with him playing cards with other presidents.
You know?
That's how bad it was.
I imagine it would sort of control the other presidents too,
to have this very intimidating guy there.
He couldn't have eaten one or two
because Garland wasn't going to tell him.
Garland and Omer Street were scaring the death of him.
I mean, he wouldn't kill him if he didn't want it.
You know?
And when he didn't care,
he didn't care about the time.
He would spend the whole name playing cards
with a few other presidents.
So this is a long way from Stuyvesant and High School
and UCLA.
Totally different.
Although it was whole meal.
And he got into a minor competition with Garland.
Garland set something to him,
which was directive.
And he turned around and challenged Garland
not immediately backed off an apology.
And then he spent the whole name there.
And that evening he was taking back
to isolation for the week.
You know?
There was another guy who was...
What was his name again?
I'm sorry.
But he had been arrested.
He had run a small room for prostitutes, streetwalkers.
And was beating them up on the side.
And he was crazy.
He wasn't actually crazy when he was close to being crazy.
And so he went very dangerous.
But he wasn't going to challenge Garland in over street.
You know?
Although he's 16 in them when they left.
So...
And then you had professional criminals.
I'm just cool then.
And I don't want to get into an argument
when Garland and Ole Miss trade.
They just walked around.
As long as they weren't pushed around,
they wouldn't do anything.
You know.
So...
What was the second night?
Well,
it was funny because...
We were told to lay down in the same place.
And...
A couple of...
The prisoners guarding us approached us to get some stuff off the line above us.
And then we sat up and said,
oh, and then we were sure that's okay.
They weren't.
And we spent the night.
You know.
The real sadist walked over and he wanted to beat us kick us again.
But by then,
Ole Miss Street 9 got another.
And Ole Miss Street had approached me and said,
ask me if I can provide him with some shoes.
He was careful.
And I said, you know, I sort of looked down and I said,
well, I don't know so far, so we were green.
Then I might run from him again.
I'm parachuting.
I was shocked he didn't have any.
And then when the sanus
tore and walked up to us and stood there staring at us
and trying to figure out
how he was going to beat us up again,
I looked up at Ole Miss Street
and was resting on top of one of them
saying, um, the tables.
And sort of pointing out to him.
And he aroused me and he realized
I felt threatened by this guy.
And since he wanted the shoes,
he needed to do something for me
that there would be a quint pro quo.
And the quint pro quo was,
he would protect us
and I would arrange for him to get shoes.
And he announced that
I don't want anything happening.
I don't want to hear anything.
And that doesn't help me that.
So we weren't kind of treated as independent.
We weren't threatened.
And then he stopped at night.
And we just went to sleep.
And how did they cheer you up?
More than the same.
We come to times
when, once his name
was in charge of the town.
One was in the name of him.
Garland.
Confedin' me once because he called me serenade.
I mean, he didn't like that.
And then,
in the name of him,
and it wasn't until
a black attorney turns watching him
and showed up that night.
Now,
of all the tanks,
for some reason,
he showed up last
at the White Realms Community Day.
And it wasn't until he showed up
that,
Omer Street
and New Orleans.
Garland.
Well, what happened is,
we got a copy of an L.A. Times article
that covered our arrest.
And Garland took that article
very personally.
It felt like he was being
an article that was identifying him.
You know,
and identifying them,
we've been meeting up, I think.
But then we sang we've been meeting them.
So, one's in until
George Washington Jr. showed up
after dinner,
that Garland began to say,
you know, identify
with George Washington Jr.
And it's George Washington Jr.
when he showed up,
put his hand up to people
and, above the conference,
called him front.
And when my conference showed up,
he turned and showed
the wound behind his left hand.
And George said,
you know, what's that?
What happened to you?
And Garland was concerned.
Because he's already been blamed
for the beating
and was taped to fall for the beating.
And he was the only one
that I went in until.
So, he went berserk,
ran out of the cell
and started running around the tank,
screaming out loud.
And he had beaten the Shen out of us.
And he would beat the Shen out of us
again if he wanted to.
And he said, what the hell is going on here?
You know?
And when I was talking with Bob,
he called out to the,
to the guard.
And the guard showed him.
And George told the guard
to pull Bob on the tank
and put him in the consultation cell,
outside.
So, he could talk to him
and say, Garland did.
And Garland just,
I thought we were dead.
I really did.
The whole time, Polaroid,
Stephen, I backed up and danced some bars.
Joe Stevenson,
with his exactly opposite.
He walked over
and sat down about
ten feet from where Garland
was doing all of those.
Screaming and running around.
And he cupped his hands.
And he was chaining his hands
and started studying Garland.
Stephenson and I were holding.
Shit! We're not.
We're going to get killed.
And we really thought that was it.
But then the guard came in
and Garland was down on the
tank, so we weren't beaten.
And the nine Super Invaders
came in and started talking to Garland.
And started to bring him down.
We said quite a lot,
20 minutes.
It convinced Garland
that, you know, he said,
I know of us not being us
and cooling.
And Garland lying through
up his hand and went back to his cell
to get out of the whole situation.
You know, away from us.
And the whole thing,
the whole time, had Polaroid.
And Garland was threatening to be in a cell.
And then they were all
sort of calmed down by the Supervisor
until after, you know,
the whole situation finally calmed down.
And we were sent to lie down
and get, well, we had a couple of hours
and which we walked around.
And then,
mom was still out for a couple of hours.
Friends just wanted to know,
our country wasn't so,
we weren't so buddy,
and we didn't know.
And then they,
everybody had to go back to bed.
And during the line-soft,
everybody had a line down.
And we were all kind of,
and we were like this,
but —
we always let too much of us
– we started to standards
enough to lane-softly,
holding stuff, you know, an isolation stuff. So we were released, we were removed and taken
to an isolation cell. When you bogged it out, we had a, you know, they had a paper for
the bond, they were taken to the cell when we were held and they were finally bogged
it out. They were held up for a couple of hours. And when we told that, you know, we
could bogged down in there, but we still weren't sure what was really going on.
You know? And then we got into an argument because Joe Stevenson then went away. He felt
we could stay there. Not worrying about being mean, not worrying about being beaten up.
Everything I called him down. Whereas the three of us, the other three said,
can't us the hell out of here, you know? And I think we were a little more realistic than
Joe was. And we then removed from there and when we started, they started bonding us out.
So they took us to downstairs to get our clothes and so I had money and we're taking down an
embezzlement where we're bonding out, you know, into the main floor of the jail and then out into the parking lot.
And we're enjoying Bob, you know, downstairs.
What happened to the other three of writers in the other tanks? Yeah, the others were still in their tanks.
You know, they didn't know what any amount any of those.
And you didn't know what had been happening with them? No.
Although we didn't think they were having the same problem. We didn't think they were being threatened.
You know? And so within a 24 hour period, we arrested, jailed, held in the tank and bonded out.
And we were taken to Theodore Hugo Brooks's home at, I don't know, midnight or so, where we had a drink and spending hours
talking about the whole experience telling them, our journey and Theodore Hugo Brooks's home, you know,
theater, what had happened and the whole thing was true.
You bonded out but you got charges against you, so what happened to you? Yeah, we were charged with unlawful assembly.
So we were out for a week. And we spent a week driving around making club speeches, trying to raise some money.
And then the corn decided they'd get the others out. So they arranged for everybody to move.
And they were all released and all of the Freedom Rider" were out on the street in a week.
Or maybe nine days, I'm not sure which. And we were waiting to be tried.
And we had a trial day, which was 30 days after we arrested. And so we had three weeks and once we're driving around, talk, and trying to raise funds for the freedom of.
And that's what we did. That's how they did.
Yeah, we did write some.
And what was the, do you remember what the local media coverage was? What were national?
The local media coverage was pretty limited. We had the use imposed in an article.
We claimed there wouldn't been being up in jail. But the sheriff claimed that that wasn't true.
So they gave the sheriff as much credit as they were more than they knew of.
One TV station came over and interviewed us. I was standing there. My arms crossed tightly wound.
In fact, they focused on my hands, which were like that. And they interviewed us. So saying we weren't being up.
But they didn't let's believe us. You know. And it didn't matter.
It didn't matter whether we didn't mean that or not. No one was going to do anything about it.
You know. So that was it.
And so you were waiting a trial day?
We had a trial day and we were waiting to try. And the trial finally came.
And we were trying, was now the old court building.
Right across from the jail. We tried to run lawful assembly.
And we had to try. The first time there once said, yeah, a mistrial.
The mistrial happened because the district attorney was trying to get rid of the phrase union center coffee shop.
Because it suggests an interstate responsibility.
And if we were coming, when we come in, like federal law.
And so they dropped union center. Just a union coffee shop.
Some genius. And George Washington had prepared very thorough motions.
One of which said there's a conflict here. He's not being prosecuted for trespassing against the union coffee shop.
When a real enemy was union station coffee shop. They had to be the same.
You can't have two completely different intonates. So that George, who was an ultra conservative judge, denied the motion.
They convened the jury. And the jury was in good terms. We made him one night case.
Was a good jury. And then the judge slowly and slowly dawned on the nuance.
Our attorney was right. He picked up the phone, called them, and the judge.
The judge, this judge, and just recently been appointed. He was right to suit you.
So I'm right to put it in the turn. I was looking for it.
Anyway, he put down the phone. He had a dismissal case.
And when the held up, when the reverse sound of the field.
So he dismissed the case, glimpsing apologize to the jury.
And they convened a new trial.
Now, that's the pandews. The good news is, this is the difference between Mississippi and Texas.
They willingly agreed to set the trial date.
So we would be all done within 30 days.
And we would be able to take the train back home and register for school.
Okay? So instead of really screwing us.
No, we're going to sentence for October 1st, which would kill our chances of going to UCLA.
They're accommodating us. Mississippi would have never done that.
Not at all.
So that's the difference between Texas and Mississippi.
Texas, stop. Sure, sure.
I'm doing some of the things. Mississippi would do it.
And they constantly slack and are returning.
And Texas was able to work together.
So there's a reason for that.
The reason is that the judges real often,
that our attorneys were sort of sending
a point at which we would be covered.
You know, we would be affording.
They had to be sure that the Texas lawyers were not angry.
They knew they're only two years away
from having an idea with James Farmer in terms of their own appointments with the judges.
And so they didn't really want to offend them.
They wanted to accommodate.
And that's what happened.
So they both sides accommodate.
In fact, one of them pulled one of our attorneys aside
and offered him an assignment that when we were in person.
They were trying to, you know,
they responded to realize, you know,
it might not be this way all the time.
They saw it coming.
Whereas Mississippi judges forget about it.
And that was nice.
So the day came for another trial.
And this time the jury was very bad.
None of the jurors.
We talked to a couple of jurors after the first trial.
And I remember going up to one of them
who worked for a department store,
a major department store,
and asked him what he thought he said he was hoping we wouldn't win.
Not the second guy, man.
He didn't want to have anything to do with us.
So it's strange because if we and one of the first trials
on the one hand and one of them made win,
on the other hand, we wouldn't have nothing more to litigate.
You know, we wouldn't have established the precedent.
We went on the facts.
And instead, we were tried.
The jury stayed out a little while, not after the moon.
And we were convicted.
And we maintained a complete poker face
when we were convicted.
And as soon as we were convicted,
we were out on bail, of course,
$500 bailings.
As soon as we were convicted, that was it.
We were free.
You know, I mean, we were going to,
our attorneys were going to post an appellate bond
when we had nothing more to worry about.
And we went out for lunch
and we were out on our way home within a couple of days.
On a train.
Now, the train we left on
was different from the train we came in on.
We came in on Southern Pacific.
I mean, we finally came in on Southern Pacific.
Now, when we came in, I'm sorry, I'm a little confused.
I think we finally came in on Southern Pacific.
And we left on, I can't remember what,
Union Pacific.
And we went on a new Union Pacific.
And by now, we were men, very bitter.
The girls, couple of the girls,
and Garnie Houston,
the spent a couple of days with black citizens here,
who wanted them to sort of take them around.
When I said these two guys,
who used the opportunity,
they passed us at them,
trying to force them to have sex with them.
And the girls, while I'm coming back,
and were very upset,
and had never reason to be upset.
So, what do we,
what the girls experience,
are experiencing being beaten up,
and being convicted,
when we're sure to be convicted,
and by legally,
there was no message for convicted us.
So, a lot of protect us.
We were kind of a bitter group.
And we got on the train.
And this time, instead of working with the porters,
we fought the porters.
And the porters said,
we're not angry with us.
Understandably so.
Yeah, because we were getting them a hard time.
You know?
We were getting them a hard time,
as we felt we had been training right,
and they went and titled to any consideration.
Even though they were on your side.
Yeah.
I remember coming back this time.
So,
the second day coming back with the tents,
didn't get along with the porters,
nothing was built into the relationship
that would have made it mutually supportive
or communicative.
We were going back,
and we were pissed off,
and the porters were just going back.
You know?
We didn't have any,
whether it was music or whatever it was.
No freedom songs.
Huh?
No freedom songs this time.
No.
And nothing else.
You know?
So, we returned to LA,
and got off the train in Union Station.
And then we went to a restaurant,
a lunch.
What's the name of that front restaurant we went to?
We all said goodbye to each other,
and dancing.
We went to a memory family and friends,
matured us,
and then we split up,
and the Freedom Rider" was over.
And when I was introduced to LA,
a couple of days later, a few days later,
a friend of mine,
who grand me,
and that one of the professors there
wanted me to do an oral history project,
and they sent me over to the UCLA oral history project,
and that's when I hung her now,
and the final result point,
where we were taking so much,
I was saying so much,
and there's so much details you can tell from my printout,
that the oral history project was coming to me,
so Steve, stop it, stop talking.
You know, dammit, you know,
there was one woman who was typing for weeks at a time,
and...
Four hundred pages of transcripts.
Yeah.
And I wouldn't stop.
And then later, a couple of years later,
the same people came to me and said,
you know, when Glendru did that,
you have a great oral history project.
Most of oral history projects went that good.
They had a lot of bullshitt oral history projects,
and Tom Rowland's oral history project was a joke.
So I did a big time,
and then later,
first of all, the summer apple,
and my own expense, I went back to you,
and get more information.
And that's why I realized
that Honeham Brooks,
you know, was on the other side of the line
in terms of crime,
although he bailed us out.
He put up a $35,000 land bond,
you know, land bond,
that there's a sale of them.
You know, the sale of them in a couple of pounds.
And, you know,
that's when I learn more
about the Progressive Youth Association people
and their backgrounds.
Progressive Youth Association?
No, progressive.
PYA, Progressive Youth Association.
And, you know,
more about their background.
Learn more about Georgia's background
and Hamas background.
I went on Georgia and Ham
and my next time,
it's sold out big time
to John Connally,
who was running an insuraftly arbor
for the U.S. Senate.
I believe with the U.S. Senate,
I'm not sure what's going on.
And Washington,
you know, I'm not going to pay it off.
So everything they did
was pro-Connolly.
And,
which wasn't right, you know.
But still,
I was digging into that
and getting some of that information.
I'm trying to get Bob back home
to sue the sheriff
and he wouldn't do it
because at that time,
there was no law
supporting such an action, you know.
One of the several years later,
that there was law
supporting that kind of law.
Then I returned to UCLA
and came back later.
And meanwhile,
I was trying to get everything out of being now, you know.
And,
interviewing with an assistant
who was returning
didn't give a shit.
There was a black assistant
who was returning an in-care.
And Ralph Jornbrough was a liberal politician,
a great god.
Who can't, but
once it's going up,
sometimes I'm up
and running money out.
So, that's what happened.
When you're back at UCLA,
trying to preserve your studies,
I assume, but also,
did you resume your political activity?
Yeah, I went to town.
I mean, I didn't care.
I was out to exploit
my role as a Phenobarbital.
And being the big time Phenobarbital
and mr. Phenobarbital on that campus.
And by then,
I had a hernia in a list in my bag.
The pain had subsided.
The pain had not subsided.
But some of the aches and pains
subsided,
leaning me with a very painful disk.
And I went to UCLA.
I checked into the UCLA
and I was playing
student health center for a month.
You know,
it was painful.
And
I was online,
I was buying almost everybody up.
And exploring it.
You know?
Well,
I don't know.
Anything involving Phenobarbital
and I was a leader.
You know?
Did the others experience the same thing?
No.
I took it to the health.
I played it to the health.
And there was nothing wrong with that.
Many respects.
But only when I played it to the health.
I developed
additional
standing as a freedom run.
You know?
Additional things.
Whenever I'm like
giving talks.
You know?
Whenever.
And you know,
was known as a freedom run
and being up in jail
from then on.
With reinforce my feelings
I've been having a question.
You know, I started reinforce myself.
And you know,
you're contributing to my standing in the movement.
I was the only one on the West Coast.
And that experience.
So over a period of time,
I was exposed to more and more people.
And I wouldn't
do more and more things.
Anybody who came to LA
whether it was trucking through
or who made mine me.
We're checking with me.
Did you maintain
close contacts with core?
As close as I could.
Can't see New York had tried to look up Jim Farmer.
That was pretty much ignored.
But I remember buying a farm in the book
and reading it while I was waiting for him
to drop out of the office.
I mean, again, I completely analyzed
both Farmer and Core.
And got to know more and more about them.
No.
So what happened with the appeal?
Oh.
It went to the Texas Court of Criminal Appeals.
And they voted to reverse our conviction.
Which they did.
Ironically,
one in the black Freedom Rider"
was particularly intelligent and well-educated.
They discovered a Texas statue
that said you cannot discriminate
against people based on their race in transportation.
So here we had a statue
that apparently been passed
as they were desperately trying to bridge a situation
with overseas visitors or whatever.
And we already had the statue we needed
to protect our rights
to take the train.
And yeah.
What else?
I'm just going to pause for a second
and talk about when you're back
and you say, well, am I a national student association?
Do we talk about that?
Okay.
So we're back.
And if you could tell me a little bit about
after you've come back from the freedom ride,
the work that you're doing, especially
with the national student association.
I was kind of dabbling
in the national student association,
although I didn't know
over a four or five-year period.
I was able to do both
because they didn't know what was overlapped.
I kept going to national student comment room
and I was threatening to run
for national office.
And finally,
I had a very bad Congress
which I really screwed up and did very badly.
And instead of running for national office,
I was offered this job of civil rights director,
which actually was much better.
And I became civil rights director,
moved to Philadelphia for a year,
and lived in Philadelphia
because I know that his headquarters
was located in Philadelphia.
Okay?
From day one, I was involved with the movement.
My very first event
was a trip to Atlanta
for Inter-Agency Conference of Civil Rights Organizations"
of civil rights organizations
and then to Jackson
and my co-maness of SIPH
for demonstrations.
So,
I remember arriving
arrived in Jackson, Mississippi,
checked in with SNCC
and drove down to McComb.
There had been 11 bombings
and 22 days in McComb.
This was after Andrew Goodman, James Chaney, Michael Schwerner's run
on a chaining were murdered.
And then I was in Atlanta.
Okay, well, not right after.
So, it was a very month after.
But what happened is that
the civil rights movement
was starting to hold the instinct
to start a holding demonstration
in the McComb.
It was really the headquarters
in Mississippi.
What was it called?
Huh?
No, it was very similar.
The White Citizens' Council.
Yeah.
And so, we drove down McComb.
And as I flew into Meridian, Mississippi,
I was in the state of Mississippi
from Atlanta.
And from Meridian, Mississippi to Jackson,
they're closer I got to Jackson
the more scared I got.
And I really started against fear
because all I had was my imagination
for more than a year.
Probably because I have a bipolar condition.
That had really run in Scotland.
I mean, I was having dreams every night
for a year, at least.
And reliving everything.
I still have a dream, in case I'm sorry.
So, we arrived in Jackson,
running in car,
visiting SNCC,
and drove down to McComb,
and checked into, I'm here, one.
Probably, once the main turn around.
Motel, holiday, and, or whatever.
Then we went through a rally.
By now, I am really scared.
Okay?
I mean, I'm having a hard time holding myself together.
It's a good thing I'm not really panicking.
We had to rally,
return to our motel,
and about four o'clock in the morning,
we pulled out to catch the plane at the airport.
And so we pulled out,
we're running across the link station.
Our police officer opens the door,
and opens the door,
and once his hands on his head,
he means out the door,
and stands out.
That's just why you're telling us, you know.
You know, don't come back.
And so we drove back to the airport,
and flew back to the lab.
And that was the story,
that was that trip.
What else?
What kind of things were,
what kind of civil rights activities
was the natural humanization involved in it?
Well, this is where it gets interesting.
First of all, I have to tell you very candidly,
but not very modestly,
I was probably the best,
um,
a staff person
on the domestic asylum and menace.
And I started off running away,
raising money
for the 1964 Thanksgiving Fast for Freedom.
So that the 1964 Thanksgiving Fast for Freedom
would subsidize the purchase
of canned goods and what happened
to feed people in Mississippi.
Okay?
Interestingly enough, what happened is,
we raised $38,000,
and it was a substantial amount of time.
But what happened, I was, you see,
I was going 24 hours a day,
psychologically incredible,
driving myself.
And, um,
I felt kind of guilty.
I didn't feel I had handled myself right.
I felt like I had exploited the movement.
And I wanted to come back to right by the movement.
Yeah.
Even though I had done right by the movement,
still not as right as I want to blame to.
So I came up with the idea
of
petitioning the Department of Agriculture
to take the $38,000
and use it to sign up as many counties
in Mississippi as you could
to the surplus room for nothing.
Okay?
And on top of that,
I came up with the idea.
You have to understand,
my mind was going 24 hours a day.
I mean, these, I think,
I'm very creative with decisions on the one hand,
on a tremendously driven on the other hand.
Okay?
And I'll explain some of the consequences of this.
So I said to Steve Robbins,
who is president of National Student Association,
a friend from UCLA,
you know, when you aren't going to the commission on
religion and race,
National Council of Churches,
and trying to have a relationship
with them to do this.
And they certainly have more going
for them than we do.
They had programs in the Mississippi,
you know,
and elsewhere in the South.
And he agreed to sign content of Robert W. Spike,
and he put,
who was head of the commission on religion and race.
And he, he, he put me in triumph,
in touch with Art Thomas,
who was head of the Delta Ministry.
And Art and I,
we started organizing this.
And by then,
I was participating in the leadership conference
on civil rights and Washington,
and using contacts I made in Washington,
they'll see run
with civil rights,
civil rights rights,
I think, for the Department of Agriculture.
And we started putting the scheme together, okay?
At the same time,
the guy who was in charge of the surplus food program,
saw his opportunity to expand the program.
And we went to court,
except I was pissed off,
because instead of actually
distributing food,
and the handing of program,
we started knocking off counties.
County after county,
this was a guy who didn't listen to parliament.
And he would go to the county and say,
hey, listen,
I've got the National Student Association here,
and the National Health Fund Services.
And if you don't join our program,
there's something like only less than 20%
of Mississippi's surplus food program
is actually enrolled in the Semini surplus food.
He said,
we'll just give the money to the...
We'll let the Commence of the Legislative Rights Network
and distribute the food and you'll have them in your county.
Of course, no county wanted them, right?
They didn't want the Commission
and did the National Health Fund Services in their county.
And so, as time passed,
that fall went through the spring,
and we started rolling more and more counties
until by spring time,
every county in Mississippi
was enrolled in the surplus food program,
and this guy wanted us to shift to Alabama.
I was hysterical,
but I was pissed off
because I actually wanted to see food distributed.
But it wasn't big.
No, but he didn't think this guy was actually right,
and that was a menoral turn.
So, that's what happened.
And we had a Thanksgiving
when schools and colleges all over the United States,
fasting,
and when we were getting the money,
and one of them used to buy food,
then they want to use to buy food
was going to us for this program.
And this one's down beautiful.
It was great.
And through the program,
what actually happened?
Well, what happened in the Amin County
in the state of Mississippi joined
the surplus food program
in the Department of Agriculture.
And they got...
Yeah.
And what happened through them?
Food was distributed to Amin County in Mississippi.
Black people who couldn't get food before
were getting food.
So, when we took the surplus food program
once we resigned,
maybe 70% in rural
boosted it to 100%.
And black is all over the state
when getting food.
surplus food and living on.
So, that's an agenda of St. Collins.
And we also had something called
Books for Equal Opportunity.
Me,
when we raised books,
we got students and institutions
to donate books to Mississippi.
And now what's going on?
So, those were two major programs
that we were,
you know, we had called to happen.
And then what was next for you?
We were also deeply involved in the leadership conference
on Civil Rights.
Passers-in to 1964 Civil Rights Act.
And later the Voting Rights Act.
And we got...
I'm going to White House pen".
He used to...
sign the Voting Rights Act.
That was invited to the ceremony.
So, I...
one of the things I have at home is the White House pen".
So, what kind of things did you do to support those acts?
And how important do you think of that?
Participate in the Leadership Conference of Civil Rights.
Which is the Civil Rights Law being watching.
So, once they're willing to watch it.
And participate.
And try and go into them doing more.
They got so many hate in me.
Because every time I'm showing up I'm into a man more.
You know?
And with funny.
Everybody else was organized like that.
They hate it's not.
So, when I showed up and mentioned when I learned that once at SNCC every week,
they didn't like me either.
But there were a couple of very important people who knew.
So, now.
Damn.
So, once those acts were actually adopted,
how did you feel that you were accomplished?
Or you needed to accomplish?
We accomplished a lot more.
When I'm important back to the NASA student in London,
the next summer, the next summer, the 65,
they were fliming at the NASA.
I mean, when you accomplish more,
and one year they're going to say,
and accomplish it in its entire history.
You know?
And the civil rights and rights that some replaced me.
If I may say so,
didn't hold a candle when I was new.
Didn't get anything like that but a notification?
Nothing.
They were basically watching,
going to the motion.
They weren't doing much.
They weren't streaming the time.
What made you say, driven these things?
Well, part of it,
was that when I,
we didn't even have to fill it up yet.
I would spend time in New York.
And what's you knowing the nation?
We had the massive,
simple freedom of government kind of parting
with organizing Congress people
to try and get them home.
For Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party and Senate of the Mississippi delegation,
one of the people I met there was Rita Schwerner.
And Rita and I became quite close.
Rita Schwerner,
Mickey/Michael Schwerner's widow,
and we became quite close.
And she was a real conscience for me.
Not that I didn't have a conscience.
But if anything, she accentuated.
She was more militant than I was.
She was great.
Very strong, folks.
Had a mind like Steel Thrap.
Once committed to Minkie and his memory.
And many opportunities, six points,
I never explained it.
She was a piece of work.
And she was Rita Schwerner.
Although most people didn't realize that.
People in the movement on this said,
people like Gloria (Richardson) and Gia,
and John Lewis,
all of them,
when Minkie was killed,
John Lewis sent Bob Zelner,
white son of him,
and experienced some of white's,
and the statements were until enough.
And he knew.
And he has a corner for a few days.
I lived in Washington,
and now he's trying to make these speeches.
So,
I had a lot to do with it.
You know?
I was a purest.
You know, take this very five or four minutes,
and thought about a minute and say,
sorry, that's all I know.
I was a purest.
That's when I had my MFDP.
And I became a member of the MFDP Congressional Strategy Committee.
So, I got to the point where once a week I went to the United
Washington for a strategy meeting,
which was extremely urgent.
I was exposed to the whole MFDP.
When I returned to UCLA in the fall,
I arranged with the National Health Law Services
to send me to Washington for two weeks
so I could investigate exactly what happened.
I was able to establish that the White House
and in and being behind the scene
to oppose the challenge.
And nobody knew that.
You know? But it was true.
The guy in the AFLC, I don't kept telling me that.
And so,
and then when I was with,
when I was with,
and with the MFDP,
Walter Reuther's brother
tried to put a watcher in Trinket County,
Tim Dimmer, which was nice.
So, I was sworn in that these,
I happened to be in certain places at certain times.
Yeah, I was.
Let me just ask a final question if I could,
which is, ask you if there's anything else that you'd like to say
or anything that I should have asked about that I didn't have.
It's a shame that the AFLC,
I am especially in the NAACP,
was so enticed.
Hey, hey, it's,
and I mean painting.
I couldn't even talk to anyone in the analytic game I was doing.
I tried to think that Clarence Mitchell Jr was handling the end of my scene
being office,
to attend a meeting
in the
Sanitary America Office,
and the office,
about food distribution,
and what to do with it.
I was invited and excuse,
So, around today,
I was terrible.
Dimmer Pellano.
They saw the AFLCIO
was largely populated in the leadership confidence.
By people who were either the children,
or the violence,
or maybe all the associates
of AFLCIO people
who were involved in the 1930s organizing the law.
They were fought to the communists,
and so they were convinced.
They saw all the snip people,
many of whom's parents
have been communists in the 30s.
And so they just
adamantly opposed them.
One of the realities,
these guys went out to explain them.
You know?
And so that's what happened.
It's a shame, but it's true.
Well, I think we'll stop there.
That's all right with you.
Sure.
And let me just thank you one more time.
By pleasure.
That's all right.
No problem.
Thank you.
You know, by all means.
Okay.
It's an honor for us to get to work.
My honor.
Okay.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.